.
OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY
TONIGHT.
BUT ON ANOTHER STORY, OUR R&B
SUPERSTAR MONICA IS RECEIVING
PRAISE AFTER SHE STOPPED HER
SHOW IN DETROIT WHEN SHE
WITNESSED A MAN ALLEGEDLY
ASSAULTING A WOMAN IN THE
CROWD.
I WANT YOU TO WATCH THIS
MOMENT.
THE SINGER JUMPED OFF THE STAGE
AND INTO THE AUDIENCE TO
CONFRONT THE ATTACKER.
WATCH.
>> NO, DON'T YOU HITTER LIKE
THAT.
LISTEN, LISTEN, LISTEN, IF YOU
DON'T GET THAT OUT OF HERE.
YEAH, YOU NEED TO --
YOU ARE OUT OF YOUR MIND.
T
ALTERCATION WAS SATURDAY, NIGHT
IT WAS CAUGHT ON TAPE, IT IS
NOW GONE VIRAL ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND MONICA IS HERE WITH US, AND
SHE JOINS ME NOW.
MONIKA, REALLY, I MEAN, I
WATCHED THIS WEEKEND, I WAS,
LIKE WOW.
IT IS INCREDIBLE TO SEE YOU
MAKE THE DECISION TO DO THAT,
WHAT MADE YOU SHOP OFF THAT
STAGE?
WHAT DID YOU SEE?
>> HONESTLY, THAT WAS JUST
INSTINCT, AND I KNOW THAT
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW WAS
PERSONALLY OR ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL, BUT THE FEW THAT DO KNOW
THAT EVERYTHING FOR ME AS A
MATTER OF THE HEART, IT IS A
MATTER OF I AM, RON I AM A
SISTER.
I AM A MOTHER.
I SAID MOM.
I AM SO MANY THINGS THAT WOULD
ALLOW SOMEONE TO WANT TO
PROTECT ME.
SIMPLY PUT, I DIDN'T WANT TO
SEE HER HURT OR HARMED, AND HER
NOT MAKE IT BACK HOME AFTER
COMING JUST TO BE A CONCERT
GOER FOR MYSELF AND A ASHANTI
WHO IS ALSO ON THE SHOW.
YOU, KNOW THESE CONCERTS HAVE
BECOME WHAT ALMOST FEELS LIKE A
DANGEROUS SPACE AND PLACE, AND
I JUST REALLY WANT THAT TO
CHANGE.
SO THAT IS JUST MY INSTINCTS
KICKING IN.
I DO NOT FEEL LIKE I AM SOME
FORM OF SUPERHERO IN ANY FACET.
BUT I DID WHAT I WOULD HOPE
THAT SOMEONE WOULD DO IF THEY
SAW THAT HAPPENING TO MY AUNT
OR MOTHER, I COULD TELL THAT
SHE WAS, SHE IS DEFINITELY
MILDER.
AND THERE WAS A LEVEL OF FEAR
THERE FOR ME, JUST WATCHING
WHAT APPEARED TO BE A SITUATION
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN ESCALATED
EVEN FURTHER, I WAS SIMPLY
TRYING TO DE-ESCALATE.
>> WHEN YOU JUMPED DOWN THERE,
YOU CONFRONTED THE MAN WHO YOU
SAW ALLEGEDLY DOING THIS, WHAT
DID YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> NO, IT WAS MORE SO, AND I
KNOW THESE DIFFERENT VIEWS AND
VIDEOS, I AM STILL GETTING USED
TO THE IDEA OF THINGS GOING
VIRAL.
BECAUSE IN MOMENTS LIKE SUCH,
YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT THAT, I
AM FROM AN AREA THAT IS
PRE-INTERNET.
NONE OF THAT CROSSED MY MIND.
WHAT I WAS ATTEMPTING TO DO WAS
TO GET SECURITY WHO WAS
STANDING THERE.
I DON'T THINK THEY WERE ABLE TO
HEAR OR UNDERSTAND ME ASKING
THEM TO REMOVE THEM, HE
SPECIALLY ONCE THE SITUATION
STARTED TO TRANSPIRE.
SO FOR ME IT WAS ALL INSTINCT
BUT WAS SIMPLY JUST A MATTER OF
THE HURT.
I DIDN'T WANT TO SEE HER, I
DIDN'T WANT TO SEE HER HIT
AGAIN.
I DIDN'T WANT THEM FIGHTING,
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT ALL
PARTIES SHOULD KEEP THEIR HANDS
TO THEMSELVES.
WOMEN SHOULDN'T ADVANCE, MEN
DEFINITELY SHOULD NOT HIT
WOMEN.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WE DON'T HAVE, THERE IS NO WIN
FOR US FOR THEM, THEY ARE
NATURALLY STRONGER, AND THERE
ARE SITUATIONS THAT MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT OUTCOMES, BUT I AM
GRATEFUL THAT BOTH OF THEM MADE
IT HOME SAFELY.
BECAUSE ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THAT, I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
HAVE EVER IMAGINED BEING
ONSTAGE AGAIN IF SOMEONE WAS
HURT IN A VERY SERIOUS MANNER
AT A CONCERT.
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE A PLACE
OF JOY AND FUN.
AND I JUST PRAY THAT PEOPLE
START TO GOVERN THEMSELVES
BETTER THEIR.
YOU KNOW?
I THINK THERE WAS A LOT TO BE
LEARNED FROM OUR SIDE AS FAR AS
SECURITY GOES.
THE VENUE SIDE I SUFFER AS
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IT IS THE
VENUES RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY TO
KEEP THEM SAFE.
BUT I JUST DID NOT WANT TO SEE
SOMEONE HARMED IN A MANNER THAT
WOULDN'T ALLOW THEM TO MAKE IT
BACK HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THAT CAN VERY EASILY HAPPEN
WHEN YOU ARE FIGHTING AT A
CONCERT.
>> SO MANY ARTISTS FACE THIS
EXACT DILEMMA ABOUT WHETHER TO
STEP IN, WHETHER TO STOP THE
SHOW OR KEEP GOING, ARE YOU
HEARING ANYTHING FROM POLICE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
THESE TWO PEOPLE?
WHAT ARE YOU BEING TOLD?
THEY GAVE US A STATEMENT SAYING
THAT THEY ARE STILL
INVESTIGATING AND THAT NO
POLICE REPORTS HAVE BEEN FILED.
WHAT ARE YOU BEING TOLD
ANYTHING?
>> I WASN'T TOLD ANYTHING.
THE ONLY THING I ASKED WAS WAS
EVERYONE OKAY.
AND I WAS TOLD THAT BOTH
PARTIES WENT HOME, EVERYONE WAS
OKAY.
AND THAT WAS MY GOAL IN THAT
MOMENT.
ANYTIME I, YOU KNOW, I'M TOLD
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THERE IS
BEEN AN ISSUE OR PROBLEM OR I
HAVE SEEN SENIORS BEING STRUCK
WITH ITEMS THAT CONCERTS, I
THINK THE OVERALL CONVERSATION
NEEDS TO BE NOT JUST ABOUT THIS
ONE INCIDENT, BUT ABOUT THE
ACTIONS AND BEHAVIORS WHEN
THESE FESTIVALS AND CONCERTS
ARE HAPPENING.
IT IS ALL DANGEROUS, FOR, US
FOR THE PUNTER GOERS, AND
THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO BE HAVING A
GOOD TIME, EVERYONE IS SUPPOSED
TO MAKE IT BACK HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND EVERY PERSON THAT TRAVELS
WITH ME KNOWS HOW I FEEL ABOUT
PEOPLE.
I AM NOT A GIRL'S GIRL WANTING
TO BE FAMOUS.
I AM OVERLOOKING HER FAMILY, MY
FAMILY IS FROM NOON, GEORGIA.
WE SLAPPED HOGS AND WE LOVE
EACH OTHER SO MY.
FEELING WHEN I SEE SOMETHING
HAPPENING IS A FEELING OF
COMPASSION AND CONCERN, THE
OTHER STUFF IS NOT IMPORTANT TO
ME.
>> WELL IT WAS REALLY
REMARKABLE TO SEE YOU DO WHAT
YOU DID.
AND, I MEAN, I HAVE TO, SAY I
MEAN, YOU CAN ALL BE WORRIED
ABOUT YOUR OWN SAFETY HAVING
SINGER HERSELF JUMP INTO THE
CROWD.
BUT CLEARLY YOU DID IT BECAUSE
OF CONCERN FOR KEEPING
EVERYBODY SAFE AS YOUR SHOW.
MONIKA, WE APPRECIATE YOU,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, I WANT EVERYBODY
TO GET HOME SAFE FOR THEIR